not well unfortunately the uh the
government have missed yet another
opportunity to put this uh right we came
here in good faith uh what they want to
talk about is productivity
productivity when our members are
working 18 hour shifts quite how you
become more productive with that I do
not know but today unfortunately despite
us showing up in good faith
the government had missed yet another
opportunity to put this right and what
will happen is that the strike action
taking place by United members our
ambulance workers and I think it is
important to remember this is about
across the NHS this isn't just nurses
everybody works across the NHS is just
as important our ambulance members will
be taking strike action uh on the uh on
the 23rd so very disappointed today but
unfortunately not surprised
dimension of a one-off payment
no no the uh all that the government are
interested in is saying that in order to
justify a payment then we need to find
we need to come up with productivity
savings uh in the NHS that is absolutely
uh ludicrous this isn't a factory we're
talking about we are talking about
people who are working well beyond their
contracted hours anyway just to get the
job done because I can't hand patients
over and because they care so much so
for the government to be talking about
productivity in exchange for a payroll
is an insult to every single one of our
members you all know what's going on in
hospitals at the moment you all know how
hard everybody is working so today's an
insult to our members did they talking
about a one-off payment in exchange for
some sort of improvement to productivity
all they talked about today was if we're
going to open discussion about a payment
then there'll need to be discussion
about productivity a payment for this
financial year well you tell me exactly
and for fortunately I don't think today
made that any clearer there were mixed
messages yesterday and today did not
make that any clearer but I emphasize
the thing to get out of today that is
absolutely clear is that is that no one
our members to give more in order for
them to consider a payment and that is
absolutely outrageous so the strikes go
on absolutely yes